Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
deadpool 3 marvel video all about the cancelled
movie that they were going to do with deadpool and
wolverine ryan reynolds revealed a whole bunch of
details it's really cool there's a bunch of easter
eggs and connections so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel i do marvel videos
every week i'll be doing marvel loki episodes in a
couple weeks when that starts be sure to subscribe
to get everything also bring back the giveaway for
disney plus memberships because those episodes
are getting ready to start all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions for deadpool 3 on the video so ryan
reynolds has been talking a lot about deadpool
3 the past couple of years since disney bought
fox that deal closed around avengers end game
coming out in theaters that's how long it's been
every time he does an interview for one of his
other big upcoming movies they always ask him
for deadpool 3 updates and he's clarified on his
side of things and kevin feige the disney ceo on
the other side of the table have clarified still
going to be a rated r movie they're still going
to let them do his own thing but also eventually
cross him over into the mcu movies so it's not
like they're suddenly going to force deadpool
3 to be pg-13 just for the purposes of fitting
him into the marvel cinematic universe but then
something really cool happened earlier this year
and you probably saw ryan reynolds posting about
a wolverine and deadpool team-up movie that he
and hugh jackman were going to make he literally
posted this to his twitter feed and clarified that
it was not meant to be a joke he's 100 serious
they had been developing deadpool 3 to be a
deadpool and wolverine team-up movie it would have
been a little smaller in scale more on the level
of the logan movie in the first deadpool movie you
may have also seen that funny wolverine origins
reunion that they had as part of this larger fox
x-men actor reunion even leave schreiber got in on
the joke this is just you and me logan i guess
so you know uh you know what that makes this a
reunion for x-men origins reunite yeah one of my
favorite things about their friendship is just how
willing they are to take shots at themselves but
per ryan reynolds explanation the basic premise of
deadpool 3 was that it would have been a deadpool
wolverine road trip movie in the story would
have unfolded in the style of a rashamon movie
i'll explain that in a second but when he says
deadpool and logan in his tweet here he's talking
about the older version of wolverine because this
would have been after the logan movie had come out
and i was a huge ackman even though he is a boss
looks a little bit older than the younger version
of wolverine from 20 years ago and because
wolverine died in that movie it would have taken
place before the events of the logan movie that's
sort of meant to take place at the end of the
timeline of these fox x-men films if you remember
deadpool 2 actually came out in theaters after the
logan movie and he used the opening scene to make
fun of hugh jackman for killing off wolverine like
joke's on you because i'm dying in this one too
then he lights up the gas tanks and it turns into
this big parody of a james bond style intro with
the song from celine dion i did give him points
for trying something like that but i still think
the opening credit scene from the first deadpool
movie was better so we'll see if they can top that
with the deadpool 3 opening credits scene but
when ryan reynolds said that the story would
have unfolded rashman style if you haven't watched
a bunch of classic akira kurosawa or samurai films
many of his films are so iconic that they've been
ripped off hundreds of times with newer films
the most famous example is george lucas saying
that the original star wars movie a new hope was
mostly inspired by the plot of hidden fortress
but now when people refer to the rashamon effect
when they use it in their stories it's all about
the idea of an unreliable narrator viewers see an
event from multiple contradictory vantage points
and thus the audience is meant to have no idea
who's actually telling the truth the original
movie was a murder mystery someone gets killed
and the movie is them basically going through
this trial after the fact trying to learn the
truth hearing testimony from what happened from
how this person died from three different people
and each of them tells a very different story
about what happened and even though the movie
was from 1950 just careful spoiler warning for
the plot of rashman if you haven't seen that yet
because it is important to how the ryan
reynolds deadpool 3 movie with wolverine
would have played out eventually they find out
in that original rashomon story that all three
people who had been giving conflicting accounts
of the events of the murder have each been lying
themselves giving false testimony and it's not
until a fourth person comes along who witness
the whole event from afar without being noticed
that they get the real truth and it winds up being
a much less dramatic version of events that they
had been hearing the three fake stories that the
others had been telling were all super heightened
versions of the truth like this big epic battle
took place and that was how this person wound up
getting killed when really the truth was that it
was a much less fantastical version of events it's
like asking a child how an accident happened and
they tell you this huge story when really it was
just an accident but all three of the survivors
who had been lying to them this whole time wound
up being totally rotten terrible people in reality
and the fourth person who actually tells the real
truth winds up being like the one good person
in the story even the person who wound up dying
the murder that they're trying to solve that
person winds up being pretty terrible themselves
so it's meant to be this reaffirmation like
humanity is doomed because how can people be so
terrible to each other like this but it's not all
bad because there's this one person who is truly
good so there is hope for humanity after all so
when ryan reynolds says that deadpool 3 was going
to be a deadpool and old man wolverine road trip
rashem on style it sounds like they would have
been trying to unravel a big murder mystery
like really big x-men character gets killed
they have to solve the murder and as they go
around the country trying to solve it they meet
up with big x-men marvel characters investigating
and each of them winds up lying to them about
what really happened until some other big x-men
character comes forward and gives them the real
truth in the end so you can lay your guesses as
for who the villains of that story would have
been because in the original rashomon story the
main characters are all meant to be thought of
as relatively regular upstanding citizens like
good people but who then turn out to secretly
be terrible so if they were actually going to
adhere to that trope you would use regular x-men
heroes like traditionally good characters the
surprise twist wind up being secretly bad like you
can't use a character in a role like that that you
already know to be a villain because you would
expect them to do something terrible it has to be
a big twist it has to feel like a big betrayal
in fact if we're talking about x-men stories
there's actually a really good example of this in
x-men the animated series if you never watch that
series in the very first episode of that there's
a character called morph that seemingly dies in
an attack from the sentinels then later it's
discovered that he survived and he was saved
by mr sinister who plants him back inside the
x-men again but this time as his secret agent
working to take down the x-men so it's this
huge betrayal from someone that you thought of
as a good character everyone break out your top 10
anime betrayals list i think gambit would actually
be a good pick for a story like this because
he has history with mr sinister in the comics
and he's one of those characters with a criminal
history before he became a member of the x-men
before he met rogue but you think of him as a good
character like you normally think of gambit as a
hero in fact you remember the channing tatum
gambit movie that they were talking about for
years they were trying to make that's what that
whole movie was going to be about mr sinister
was going to be the main villain and that's what
the whole mr sinister wolverine post-credit scene
was about during x-men apocalypse they were
going to use that to set up the gambit movie
essex is mr sinister's real name he was born
nathaniel essex they also kind of referenced the
essex corp during the new mutants movie because
it's the larger fox x-men universe and they were
actually going to cast jon hamm as a version of
mr sinister and that so i don't know if they were
also going to use jon hamm as mr sinister during
the channing tatum gambit movie but mr sinister
would have been the main villain his whole history
with gambit that they would have adapted for the
story of the movie is that originally when gambit
was younger he came up as a thief working for mr
sinister just pulling jobs for him then eventually
decides to leave behind his criminal ways turns
good and it's only after that that he finds
the x-men eventually winds up joining them they
kind of did that version of gambit's backstory
with taylor kitsch's version of the character
and had that movie actually done better and they
continued the storyline with direct sequels we
probably would have seen more of that version of
gambit just play out the way ryan reynolds talks
about it obviously now the current version of
deadpool 3 that we'll wind up seeing in theaters
will be vastly different even though hugh jackman
has kind of made it seem like he doesn't want to
come back to do more wolverine it's a never say
never kind of situation i'm not expecting to see
him come back to something like secret wars in
many many years and as for the channing tatum
gambit movie they kind of soft canceled that
when disney bought fox so channing tatum could
still wind up being gamut someday maybe but i'm
not expecting it i think what's going to happen
in a couple more years when they start doing new
marvel x-men movies with the rebooted versions
of the characters they'll just do a totally
different version of the gambit character with
a much younger actor but right now what's going on
with deadpool 3 is that they actually just brought
on new writers last year from bob's burgers
they're working with ryan reynolds to write
the story they've been doing that for about six
months now it's been a while currently deadpool
3 would be released sometime after the blade movie
i believe that's the plan and right now it seems
like the blade movie might get released late
in 2023 after marvel's new fantastic four movie
like you saw that big marvel phase 4 trailer i'll
post a link to my video for that at the end of
this and down in the description because they
basically tell you the order for all the marvel
movies that are happening during marvel phase four
and early marvel phase five in the fantastic four
movies at the end of that with no date that's
probably going to wind up being july 2023 so
blade would be like the next movie right after
that then after that theoretically would be the
deadpool 3 movie so sometime during 2024 and based
on what kevin feige has said about them developing
their new marvel x-men movies it sounds like those
might start getting released around 2024 maybe the
year after that they could always wait till after
avengers 5 to start releasing those x-men movies
but we'll see actual x-men characters and mutants
showing up in the mcu long before that like by
that time you will know exactly how mutants in
x-men exist in the mcu we'll start seeing more
easter eggs for that during the marvel eternals
movie later this year so when i do more eternals
videos i'll start explaining more on how that sort
of leads up to the reveal of x-men and mutants in
the mcu but everyone let me know in the comments
what do you think about this version of deadpool 3
that ryan reynolds said that he and hugh jackman
were going to make together it actually sounds
like it would have been pretty fantastic everyone
click here for my video on that huge marvel phase
4 trailer and click here for that brand new
thor 4 love and thunder first look and learn
all about thor's new hammer thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and maximum effort!